hey youtubers is charlie a surprise
surprise there's Warcraft footage so
equip your rain gear meet me at
Blackrock foundry and let's break it
down raise your hand if you are at one
point or are still addicted to World of
Warcraft note no judging I feel like you
can't call yourself a warcraft fan if
you haven't been addicted to it at some
point to the detriment of the rest of
your life Rob Kazinsky who's playing a
Grimm here said that he actually lost
one of his girlfriend's to warcraft
henry cavill missed the first call that
he got Superman like that he was cast as
Superman because he was in a raid with
his guild so I hear you're a big world
of warcraft fan I certainly have played
a lot in the past yeah what's your most
memorable rain that's a very good
question she's lair when it first came
out yeah there there's so many people at
so many levels of society that have
played warcraft and i feel like we need
our own support group but the movie
actually looks pretty awesome it's in
the vein of avatar where it's like this
immersive CG world I wouldn't be
surprised they do some sort of VR tie in
with the movie whenever it's released
next year most of the people that are
making VR headsets like Sony and valve
are starting to release on this
Christmas shopping season so usually
like it takes a good six months before
you start seeing really good software
for stuff like that you see the console
first you see like one or two big
release titles and then several months
later you start to see the really cool
stuff so hopefully by the time the movie
comes out they'll have some interactive
VR content but even though this clip is
super short and there's not a lot of
like close up of the faces there are a
lot of familiar actors here that you'll
recognize from other places Dominic
Cooper is playing king lane rin now this
is like a couple different versions but
most of his history is tied up in orcs
versus humans my initial interaction
with the game was with Warcraft 2 we
used to play it in the physics computer
lab in high school just because they
were all networked max so you can duel
and play with a couple different people
that's also a good pull to take raise
your hand if you got caught playing
warcraft some instance of warcraft
warcraft to warcraft 3 on a school
computer and had to stay after school
but most of my teachers were pretty cool
I never got suspended for playing
warcraft on school computers but they
wouldn't kick you out by the seat of
your pants so like just get the hell out
of here Ben Foster is playing with Eve
very famous person in Warcraft history I
remember when the first Warcraft 2
expansion came out that was one of the
coolest cutscenes ever him opening the
portal Travis Fimmel is playing an doin
are here ruth negga who you may remember
from agents of shield as plank lady
tarea paula patton playing corona bench
jets nerds playing Khadgar and then
again the Oryx you have Clancy Brown
who's playing black hand I always love
Clancy Brown everything he shows up his
is like the most amazing voice Rob
Kazinsky as i said is playing a Grimm
ryan robbins who is on arrow right now
is actually playing a character that we
don't know yet so I'm guessing that it's
kind of spoilery Daniel Cudmore who
plays Colossus at like in the classic
Bryan Singer x-men movies he's in it to
his character is also secret Toby
Kebbell is playing der Tann here Callum
Rennie is playing morose we don't seem
in this teaser here but he's such a huge
character is going to be really awesome
seeing him in just a places in the
timeline what they're doing is is
they're picking up with orcs versus
humans kinda where the Lord is around
those games and then they'll build on
that when they do future films you guys
let me know though is there a particular
period of Warcraft lore that you want
them to do a movie based on I think you
know if this first movies successful
enough they'll totally spin out a big
franchise so they'll be able to hit like
all the big stuff in Blizzard continues
to write new lore as they release new
content so as long as the movies are
good we'll keep seeing them the other
big thing too is I'm wondering is if
they're going to be releasing special
content when the movie comes out because
they released the latest patch last year
so I think they're trying to time things
so they can do stuff for the video game
and stuff for the movie in fact I think
I'll actually do like a blizzard give
away with the trailer video that I post
on Friday like when the full trailer
post all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video maybe like an epic mount giveaway
or something like that it has been a
little while since I've played the game
I'm still paying for my subscription but
I stopped playing actively after the
first patch and mists of pandaria that
was about the time when I started making
YouTube videos so that took up like
every minute of free time I had but I
still do log in to get world
achievements every once in a while
that's the thing i like about warcraft
is that like even if you go away for
like six months or a year or whatever
like if you have to go to school you
don't have time to play you can always
come back later and you'll still get a
lot of those seasonal achievements but i
don't really consider myself an
achievement [ __ ] although you do get
upset if you miss one so everybody be
sure to check the schedule again for
seasonal achievements coming up and that
in the holiday season make sure you log
in at least once so that you get them
there is big stuff happening tonight to
we're going to be Jesse quick on the
flash and there's a new agents of shield
episode I think we're supposed to learn
who lash
going to be so why he has later all that
stuff to post you can click here for my
last flash trailer video and you can
click here for you know potential reveal
about Ray's character and star wars the
force awakens there was a toy commercial
that may have given a few things away
about her character toys says to do that
all the time for Disney movies but thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you